welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3's
villain the high evolutionary is an even
bigger mystery than we realize a
backstory completely removed from his
canonical lore in the pages of Marvel
Comics as James Gunn has confirmed that
this character is not actually named
Herbert Windham that is the name of the
earth scientist who is the high
evolutionary in the comics and how I've
been referring to Chuck Woody uchi's
character in videos but rather the
character is an entirely different
extraterrestrial character of gun's own
creation it's an important question
because the high evolutionary is still
alive and may return rocket refused to
kill him and chikuyuji confirms you do
not see him go down with a ship and if
you don't see someone die they are still
alive and a VFX artists confirmed that
you can definitely see Drax carrying the
high evolutionary off of that ship so
the evolutionary is somewhere on nowhere
I guess making James Gunn coming up with
this different backstory for him all the
more important to us now doing this
isn't really new for the MCU where the
movies often change characters names and
backstories from the precise lore of the
comics like ego in the movies was the
celestial not so in the comics and MCU
Namor is still a mutant but in the
movies he comes from talocon instead of
Atlantis in the comics he remains was a
Kang variant in the MCU instead of an
elderly TBA employee separate from
immortus or anyone else in the Kang
Dynasty in the comics ultron's age the
comics lasts more than a week and Thanos
in the comics is trying to woo lady
death but in the movies he's kind of a
malthusian eco-terrorist but what makes
this High evolutionary instance
interesting is that many things about
Jane's gun's version of the character
played by chakuruji lined up very neatly
with a character in the comics his
General appearance its construction of
counter Earth his creations of the any
men his experimentation on animal
hybrids his obsession with Eugenics and
hierarchy of species he even has history
on Earth and an interest in Earth
culture and humankind so for him to just
not be from Earth and not simply be
named Herbert Windham and not have a
specified backstory instead of that just
leaves us with questions about why the
studio didn't want to answer these
questions so let's try to answer them
here where does the high evolutionary
come from and what is he exactly now to
be clear I don't think Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 suffers from us not knowing
the picture it's really rocket story and
we learn everything we need to know
about the high evolutionaries Ambitions
when it comes to 89p13 but here's what
we do know about the high evolutionary
so far in the MCU James Gunn has
clarified multiple times on Twitter that
he is not named Herbert Windham once on
May 7th and then again when he was asked
to clarify on May 11th he made it clear
that the MCU version of the high
evolutionary is a different character
from Herbert Windham and a race from an
alien planet which makes sense because
in this movie he told Peter Quill that
he quote visited his his Planet but he
still called it Quill's Planet not his
own he's from somewhere else now the
high evolutionary is a humanoid who
looks like someone from Earth but the
MCU has established that many humanoid
characters can be from other planets
like the zandarians Nova Prime everyone
in the Nova Corps craglin was born on
xandar and then of course there are
certain pink-skinned Cree from holla
like Jan Rog as Guardians are humanoid
as are the people of the forested
banaheim and Thor the Dark World the
celestials designed Eternal staff
humanoid appearances despite the
eternals being synthetic beans Thanos
was an eternal but he was purple yet his
brother Eros looked like Harry Styles
now this has never been firmly
established but the implication from the
eternals film is that many of the
intelligent life species designed by
celestials evolved to just have a
general humanoid bipedal appearance now
we also know that the high evolutionary
is old the orbit core facility said that
it had been in business for the past 300
years so in earth years the evolutionary
established that company in the early
1700s The evolutionary also played music
featuring chanting in Latin the detailed
rocket was 5 000 years old now since the
Roman civilization didn't really spring
up up until the first millennium BC this
would mean There Were Somehow ancient
Romans thousands of years before any of
them organized into city-states living
on the Italian Peninsula but figured out
how to communicate with the same Latin
language to create music sang by choirs
of both men and women in the Gregorian
style in that someone was there to
record it or rather this was a recording
from the high evolutionaries much older
home planet and his ancestors sang in a
language similar to Latin or rather he
belongs to a certain order of beings in
the MCU Cosmic hierarchy that might have
actually originated the language of
Latin and like the eternals brought it
to Earth to give a leg up to the ancient
Roman peoples like the way the eternals
gave the Sumerians a dagger another race
of intelligent life gave Romulus and
Remus a language of Latin and we know
the high evolutionary did visit Earth in
the 1980s which is where he got the idea
to design counter Earth and style of an
80s American suburb and is presumably
here when he acquired raccoon kits from
a Columbus Wildlife Center on the side
it says lumbus but there are definitely
spots where a C and O could have faded
off geology is a 22 time award-winning
skin hair and body care company
recognizing Men's Health Oprah daily
hypebeast birdie Esquire and GQ their
products are built around just a handful
of powerful proven ingredients that have
been trusted by dermatologists for
decades just take a quick 30 second
diagnostic quiz geology will create a
simple and effective skin care or hair
care routine customized just for you
challenges co-wash and their deodorant
are just so great and I use them all the
time right now they're offering a
special offer for a skincare sampler
pack and geology skincare stuff is in a
league of its own geology's line of skin
care products can help you fight acne
reduce oil-ness prevent wrinkles combat
dark or puffy under eyes have smoother
hydrated skin and Target signs of aging
there's never been a better time to try
geology than right now for limited time
use code rockstars100 to get 100 off
your personalized 30 days skincare
sampler set all you have to cover is the
495 for shipping what a deal on top of
that new Rockstar's fans get an
exclusive bonus offer of up to 50 off on
an additional skin hair and body product
of your choice when you add it to your
trial click the link in the description
or go to
g-e-o-l-o-g dot i e slash rockstars100
to get started now some are speculating
that the high evolutionary could
actually be established as a Kang
variant which would be helpful to
justify how he sprung up at different
points in time this could be one
possible path to steer past that John of
the majors drama I'm just not crazy
about the idea of Marvel Studios
establishing that the next great MCU
villain in Phase five is just another
Kang variant like as everyone can at
this point I say let the high
evolutionary just stay the high
evolutionary now there could be a more
technical reason behind Guardians volume
3 not including the name Herbert Wyndham
it might be the Herbert Wyndham and the
Marvel Comics has more of an association
with the X-Men world as an associate of
Nathaniel Essex Mr Sinister an X-Men
villain Wyndham has ties with several of
the mutants of the Marvel lore including
overseeing young mutants Pietro and
Wanda maximoff when they were infants
now even though Disney acquired the
rights to the X-men with their
acquisition of fox in 2018 there is a
belief that certain lingering
contractual issues are slowing down how
much Marvel Studios is able to mention
established character from that side of
the world now this has never been
confirmed but it would explain why
Marvel Studios is dragging their feet
with the mutants still now five years
later like so far they've only featured
Ron wasserman's music saying the word
mutant a few times and bringing back
characters who already played them in
the box X-Men movies like Patrick
Stewart and Hugh Jackman for the
upcoming Deadpool 3 but no re-casting or
relaunch as of yet I'm gonna go into
this an upcoming investigation on the
Deep dive Channel but it may have just
been a thing where a character being
called the high evolutionary just
created fewer complications than using
the actual name of Herbert Windham but
let's point out that James Gunn's
version of The evolutionary Likens
himself with a God he declares at one
point there is no God that's why I
stepped in and he had a particular
disdain for the skull of nowhere calling
it quote a dead God and to me that
suggests a certain elitism a figure who
knows who the celestials are and were
and doesn't fear them or doesn't hold
them with any kind of divine status
consider this deleted line of dialogue
that should leave the Ouija told our
colleagues on comicbook.com's phase zero
podcast because that Brandon Davis
always asking the right questions there
was a scene that didn't make it in the a
line that didn't make it into the Final
Cut of the movie I think I'm okay to say
it because you've seen the movie you
know that scene way you know sort of
knock Groot and Peter Quill down and I'm
walking away and then they start doing
their thing with the guns there's a line
that didn't make it where I go kill the
human
bring me the tree do you know what I
mean so like I was very I'm always
interested in the other I'm always
interested in something I can learn from
ah kill the human bring me the tree
Barry leave the gun take the cannoli but
it also recalls the Curious moment from
James Gunn's first Guardians of the
Galaxy film with the collector tanelier
Siobhan what
that
I'm group
you must allow me to pay you now this is
what I make on your caucus at the moment
of your death of course I am Groot why
so we could turn you into a freaking
chair so could the high evolutionary
actually be part of the same race as the
other Elders of the Universe best known
for their titles more than their names
The Collector the Grand Master and the
high evolutionary all three would be
ancient eccentric collectors of
Antiquities and play things and seem to
be delighting in this universe where the
celestials are essentially an endangered
species the ncu has established that the
collector survived Thanos attack by
showing his ship flying away and the
opening shots of Loki episode 6 and the
studio deliberately spared the Grand
Master by removing what would have been
his death scene by the handsome Gore the
god Butcher and Thor love and thunder
the MCU High evolutionary could come
from anywhere in the cosmos but he
definitely fits the mold of an elder of
the universe as a Godly space Boomer who
always seemed to be able to slip away
now our upcoming live show on May 26th
sold out but we added a second late
night show for some more after dark
content tickets are available in the
description please subscribe to the Deep
dive And subscribe to our new channel
thebreak room and you can grab some
merch to support this growing Network at
nerdright.shop follow me on Instagram
and Twitter at EA boss Halloween
rockstars And subscribe to rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]